head-fuck I [ __ ] myself mentally do
you do that or no well I only went on a
couple of auditions and that [ __ ] was
the most worst time of my [ __ ] why
just because you know it was like the
first time ever try standup it felt like
that again and I hadn't felt that in
years
and I got so [ __ ] nervous and it just
I I could I quit acting like going to a
job interview every [ __ ] day and
somebody telling you [ __ ] suck yeah
you know yeah and then it just wasn't
for me
I mean I enjoy acting but then I think
it's hard for me to do what somebody
else's vision and so that which proves
that I'm not an act okay
that's exactly the opposite because I
thought that way before okay okay it's
the reason why you get nervous is
because you live in the results all
right you want to get the job yeah all
right
so bad because you know you booked one
good role it changes your life it really
does it can look at Eric Stonestreet he
was doing commercials for years bit
parts and movies this in that modern
modern family just his whole life
changes and that's what's at stake but
if you if that's in your head somewhere
in your brain when you're auditioning
it's too over you're not gonna do it
right so it's like what I do now is I
just know I'm not gonna get the job
really I want it but I just would rather
go in there and show them how I would do
it and the last bunch of them this year
have been amazing for me I mean I have
come close to a lot of things I booked
some things you know and I you have to
you know you just have the key sometimes
putting yourself in that situation
sometimes they're their vision might be
your vision sometimes you know
oftentimes they'll do a casting and it's
like an open casting all races right so
sometimes they create a character and
they leave it up to you for that the
artistic freedom to say hey you know
because I think that's what happened you
said with like Eric Stonestreet too like
they didn't think they wanted like a big
fat gay man you know to play well he
also said to me it's so [ __ ] funny I
know this is why I believe in God
I really believe this when I auditioned
for animal practice I know that granted
I hadn't done a pilot in years before
that in fact I hadn't even mean I tested
for a new girl which is okay but other
than that not close okay so I'm sitting
in this audition and he just had so
happened to be walking by who Eric
Eric's don't sure yeah okay
and I Sam audition for the singing he
goes don't worry about the lines look at
what he says yeah I mean it doesn't have
to be perfect and I go because you have
to allow yourself to make mistakes it's
you're getting one shot at it
did that that's not what they want to
see someone in doing a perfect right and
he and and I got the job and I I believe
I really believe that he just was there
at the right time for me to get that in
my head a lot of it's us in our head in
our head we [ __ ] ourselves you know I
mean and I just think that you should
whoever sent you on on these auditions
do you yourself know my manager senior
manager yeah you should encourage her to
send you on more because like a stand-up
called him a her and he looks like a
girl it says something about him women
in power positions he he believes in it
I do I always think that it should be a
woman but um you should encourage him
that feel better they just feel better
yes okay just said you all said her was
more accurate because I want you to I
want I want you to get over that damn
right because already the way you look
is hilarious yeah you're like you know
there's something about you that's like
what the [ __ ] there really is like in
terms of Koreans yeah I've never in my
life ever my life yeah nevermind even
imagine
and that's a good thing thank you I
probably need to stand up do you go onto
road only if college is now like
[Music]